aujourd'hui c'est que je soutiens
complètement le peuple ukrainien mais je
ne soutiens pas les dirigeants aux fêtes
d'ukraine comme d'ailleurs les
dirigeants de la russie en fait et puis
aussi à travers ce qu'on peut vivre à
travers l'europe et puis la france avec
cette montée d'escaladé moi c'est
vraiment ça que je dénonce aujourd'hui
et puis faudrait faire attention un
petit peu parce que je me suis fait
avoir il ya une semaine en fait faut pas
s'émouvoir en fait trop vite parce que
moi je me suis laissé un petit peu à
voir quand j'ai vu ces images qui sont
terribles qu'on peut voir aujourd'hui à
la télé et puis j'ai été fouillé un
petit peu j'étais à regarder un petit
peu ce qui se passait la première
question que je me suis posée est ce
qu'on aurait pu éviter ça moi c'est
vraiment ça que je me suis posée au
départ puis je suis tombé sur anne laure
bonnet qui fait d'énormes repartent un
reportage aujourd'hui en ukraine alors
un peu plus du côté est et puis on
apprend de la bouche de certains
ukrainien pro russe qui se font tous
bardés par l'ukraine et ça c'est ça peut
paraître dément mais c'est exactement ce
qui se passe parce que cette guerre il
faut le rappeler la dure depuis plus de
huit ans elle n'a pas commencé la
semaine dernière et je me demande si on
n'a pas fait une montée des tensions en
fait envers la russie à travers tout ce
qui s'est passé et avec un déclenchement
derrière avec des accords qui n'ont pas
été maintenu en fait sur les choses avec
aussi une rentrée possible en fait dans
l'otan qui a continué de faire monter
les choses et puis une attaque qui
arrive derrière et des sanctions qui
n'arrête pas de monter moi quand
j'entends bruno le maire sidya la
deuxième puissance mondiale on va vous a
séché économiquement je vois pas comment
on va pouvoir trouver une solution et
des retombées à travers tout ça le
malheur de tout ça c'est que tous ces
gouvernements n'ont rien à fiche parce
que le gasoil il le paye pas le gaz ils
ne payent pas il est bon il est prennent
pas sur la tronche sont dans des bunkers
ce qu'ils sont en train de trinquer
aujourd'hui c'est des habitants
d'ukraine ce qu'ils sont en train de
trinquer c'est les habitants d'ukraine
et puis demain ça sera nous quand on va
aller à la pompe qu'on va payer du
gasoil à 2 euros 50 ou des factures de
gaz qui vont être multipliées par deux
donc moi je pense qu'il faudrait une
désescalade est aujourd'hui l'ukraine a
pas besoin d'armes elle a besoin de paix
et j'espère qu'on arrivera à amener la
paix en fait après les matières
alors la passe passe il
essaye on a eu on a une table qui a été
fait pour des négociations moi ce qui
m'a vraiment surpris c'est que j'avais
aucun membre de l'otan aucun membre de
l'europe aucun membre des états unis
alors qu'ils ont ils ont que sharon et
les athées les états unis à une semaine
et demie 1 pour continuer de pousser les
choses et puis ces gens là ils sont aux
abonnés absents
j'appellerais ni dans le emmanuel après
dans la tête poutine pour lui dire bon
écoute tu es toujours d'accord bah non
en fait il peut pas être d'accord sur
les choses puisque poutine qu'est ce
qu'ils demandaient alors je ne l'excusé
pas suis je le répète je suis pas un pro
poutine ou rien du tout moi c'est les
dirigeants qui est qui m'embête mois les
seules personnes que je respecte là
dedans c'est tous les citoyens
comprennent plein la gueule mais quand
emmanuel macron avoir poutine pour rien
lui dire en fait pour moi ça reste du
cinéma footing qu'est ce qu'il avait dit
je veux pas qu'ils rentrent dans l'otan
je veux que vous arrêtiez de vous
approcher de vos frontières et puis on
va pas se mentir il ya quand même aussi
un autre problème économique c'est qu'on
voudrait favoriser la vente du gaz des
états unis et est arrêté
le deuxième pet planckeel me trompe
peut-être surnom qui a été fait soit
ouverte alors stream moi je pense qu'on
en est là aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
plutôt une guerre de territoires une
guerre d'argent et puis bah qui ce qui
va traquer je pense que c'est nous et
moi je vois pas d escalade est ce que au
niveau livre ce n'est pas une réaction
contre le gouvernement surtout entre les
manuels masse et
franchement je pense pas moi je pense
que déjà je pense qu'on s'en remet
beaucoup trop d'ailleurs c'est le seul
président d'europe 1 qui qui est tous
les
mets je sais qu'il a la présidence de
l'europe mais alors on danse et voilà
pourquoi les autres qui pourraient quand
même ramené un petit peu leur fraise
parce qu'on les entend pas trop moi je
trouve qu'on les entend pas déjà été
fait sergei j'aimerais avoir ton avis
sur ce qu'a dit au niveau ligue en fait
je vais vous décevoir mais pourquoi moi
mohammadi avait acquis anti-poutine anti
ukraine des prêts non livrés aux tirs
anti m'entraîne et pro poutine non non
c'est pas du tout ça en vidéo que je me
suis dit je vais lui rentrer dedans
parce que là il va m'énerver comme la
cime wannian comme la propagande
quotidienne est en fait dans tout ce que
au moustique aura donc tout ce que tu
viens de dire tu aimeras 90% je suis
d'accord avec toi à 90% il ya des trucs
importants sur lesquels il faudra
reprendre
mais à 90% je suis d'accord avec toi
hyundai est d'accord klein on est sûr
que je suis quand je suis d'accord par
exemple quand je suis un 10 % c'est
beaucoup je suis d'accord par ailleurs
par exemple que sur sur les choses qu'il
a dit que c'est le gouvernement qui
décide et c'est les peuples qui n'ont
rien à voir dans tout ça c'est qu'on
peut pas ou ne pas ne pas être assez de
parler parce que et marc bonnet o o na
jamais demander l'avis aux ukrainiens ni
aux russes si les russes veulent faire
la guerre et c'est lui qui craignait
refait le faire la guerre on peut pas
être d'accord ne pas d'accord avec ça on
est bien d'accord d'accord d'accord on
n'est pas d'accord on est d'accord après
sur le temps je suis pas d'accord parce
que dans tout ce que poutine avance
commun comme autant enfin comme prétexte
on
autant en emporte deux ans
physique est vraiment fatiguée
et après on va interdire les autres
bateaux
non il ya tout ça est faux bien prêter
c'est juste un prétexte c'est juste un
prétexte
alors qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'elle a
raconté encore je suis fatiguée la
inquiète on va te servir un truc glauque
plutôt d'accord fois que je vais d'abord
des gens d'accord parce que ces essais
c'est plus rare alors les beaux livres
c'est qu'alors de l'instantanéité des
chaînes infos des réseaux sociaux tout
le monde y va de sa petite phrase de son
petit tweet pour se soutenir l'ukraine
et parfois à tort le meilleur exemple
c'est la phrase de bruno le maire qui
l'a immédiatement retiré et je pense
qu'au lieu d'être dans l'émotionnel
constamment on devrait peut-être prendre
plus de temps pour analyser pour essayer
de comprendre le conflit qui est très
complexe dont on venait peut-être pas
tous les tenants et les aboutissants
c'est ce qu'on fait sur ce plateau
d'ailleurs en confrontant les parties en
essayant d'avoir la somme d'informations
plutôt d'ouvrir se positionner en
permanence et toujours plus après en
revanche quand on voit ces images qui
sont glaçantes on ne peut que soutenir
le peuple ukrainien comme l'a dit au
niveau des oliveaux livre soutient un
peu plus ce qu'il était d'accord avec
olive olives à peu près enfin dans les
grandes villes d'avis que la guerre
n'est pas bien réussir guèye d'un an et
y'avait béatrice béatrice je pense que
ce qui veut dire c'est qu'il a peur des
répercussions pour les français que les
français
tout d'un coup les agriculteurs le
lyonnais la pompe etc et you know et ça
je comprends tout à fait et je pense
aussi que le conflit prend énormément de
place à juste titre il faut en parler
parce que c'est très grave et très
important mais on oublie terre
complètement le sujet de la
présidentielle et quand même on a une
présidentielle qui arrive qui est
capital pour notre pays et il faut quand
même pas à ces mots là où vont les
sondages manuel mâcon pas passer au
premier tour elles n'ont ils
pas s'il ira passer au premier tour
emmanuel macron faille et là c'est
certain pas si son bilan on parle de
rien non mais c'est vrai que là il prend
six points toutes les semaines emmanuel
bach ou donc c'est vrai que là il est là
que j'ai vu ce matin hier 28 pour cent
vingt neuf ans dans trois semaines il a
car outre un gilles verdez moi je suis
assez choqué par ce qu'a dit oh les
beaux livres respectueusement mais en
confrontant parce que vous avez dit je
soutiens peuple ukrainien mais pas le
gouvernement ukrainien moi c'est ça qui
me choque le plus parce que si vous ne
soutenez pas le gouvernement ukrainien
ça veut dire pour moi je vous le dit les
yeux dans les yeux vous légitimez
l'accent de monsieur poutine contre les
bombes sur son peuple pardon qui jette
des bombes sur son pop art mais l'homme
est si le crash en 2006 gilles je veux
sincèrement gilles très honnêtement même
mois il ya une semaine j'aurais pu me
tromper je t'invite sincèrement aller
voir les reportages de anne-laure
week-end je connais en train d'être
censurée sur les rennais l'été au musée
du coup ça c'est un
vote je vois le peuple ukrainien qui
elle est qui explique que depuis des
mois et des années ils prennent des
booms sur la gueule par le gouvernement
ukrainien je suis désolé je ne peux pas
soutenir ce genre d'individus comme je
ne soutiens pas le reste je peux je peux
pas me permettre de les soutenir alors
lorsqu'il est ce que c'est vrai est ce
que c'est vrai ce que tu dis là il ya ça
prend parti une vérité sauf que là aussi
merci de dire son nom mais
moi je reste objectif j'essaie de
trouver toujours un objectif et mon
principe c'est le bon sens le bourg
centre pas le sens commun le bon sens
près de chez vous
ça veut dire que c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
des bombardements côté ukrainien en
direction de lougansk est de donner ce
que c'est vrai on peut pas le nier c'est
vrai que dans ces bombardements il peut
il pouvait y avoir des victimes civiles
côté ukrainien quand unis comme on a
aujourd'hui tu dis ils bombardent leur
peuple là tu te trompes tu es là tu te
trompe pas ce qui remettrait en russe
les meilleurs mon cousin russe oui mais
vivront t'es ok gb acquis qu'ils étaient
au chômage en russie et en lui ai dit tu
veux gagner du fric il a dit oui et donc
le on lui a donné le passeport ukrainien
et on a envoyé à lougansk complètement
très des photos ton cousin et mon cousin
russes préparent au russe est ok j'ai
bien séparer les 10 ou 15 jb mais dans
la protection des personnalités donc il
s'agissait souvent que des ukrainiens
alors attends attends vers l'est donc on
l'a envoyé cinq ans en ukraine qu'en lui
ai dit maintenant tu ukrainien et
maintenant tu vas jouer devant alors ma
championne elle et lui dire je suis le
peuple ukrainien et le quilliec monde
aux morts attend il ya une juge à rostov
un juge même monsieur un juge qui a le
prix de la décision ja il ya deux
semaines une décision de justice contre
hashim à de l'escroquerie de marché noir
entre l'eau rostov et lougansk de
donetsk et se juge il a dit dans sa
décision je constate que ce schéma c'est
ils ont volé des trucs à l'armée russe
qui est basée à lougansk est à donetsk
c'est un juge russe lorsqu'il va publier
ses décisions aux à moscou ils ont
commencé à trembler il y aura retiré
tout de suite ses décisions parce qu'une
décision de justice il a reconnu que
c'est l'armée russe qui est depuis huit
ans et dans ces pays merci aux morts
sous les bombes j'ai rien de mal je ne
nie pas non mais je vais me paraissait
français kiki voilà qu'ils sont un peu
au niveau lige de la posture de haut
niveau lives après tout voilà ça
ressemble tout ce qu il a cité aussi
comme si comme comme complot comme les
lentilles macron primaire pourra jouer
pour n'importe quoi voilà moi j'entends
dont on sait qu'il ya eu évidemment des
civils mors aux dents basse on le sait
parce que c'est un conflit de range quoi
c'est pas que ça me dérange pas je suis
parent est on sait que je de tous ces
problèmes géopolitiques l'hormone elle a
été trimballé dans les territoires hâtif
pro russe et elle est aussi sous le joug
de ces milices pro russes donc
effectivement pas forcément et pas
forcément aussi juste et c'est peut-être
manipuler mais moi ce qui me choque
c'est que le peuple ukrainien il est
souffrant oui ou non selon vous il n'a
pas donné beaucoup de reaching sommes
là-bas faut faire attention à vous il y
en a pas
non mais c'est ça le toujours à quai
mais qui dépensent la lettre au dollar
et leurs milliards ils sont pas
corrompues écoute alors que le peuple
crève de faim moi j'estime que le peuple
ukrainien est souverain et s'ils l'ont
pas ils ont pas vingt six ans pas envie
d'être sous le joug de la russie les six
ont envie d'être seul avec leur
gouvernement ils ont droit et s'ils ont
envie aujourd'hui d'être dans le rang
ils ont droit et l'endroit même de
changer d'avis c'est pas un putin de
décider en fait on a la chance d'avoir
une spécialiste des balkans à mal si
valérie bénaïm et à côté on a un
spécialiste des balcons
[Rires]
valérie qu'est ce que vous voulez dire à
haut niveau ligue non mais j'entends ce
qu'il dit mais voilà effectivement mais
personne ne
sait où je suis pas absolument pas
d'accord avec ce qu'il dit si ce n'est
que oui la guerre c'est mal où il ya des
morts il ya des morts des deux côtés
malheureusement dans le donbass on ne
découvre pas que depuis huit ans il ya
la guerre et que effectivement il ya des
russes infiltrés sur le territoire du
dombass qui sont devenus craignant et
que donc il ya des milices et ya des
milices des deux côtés simplement
l'ukraine est un pays souverain est un
pays qui les sites de son sort et que
rien ne justifie une invasion russe dans
un pays souverain qui est libre de
choisir
la question c'est pas tout à fait ça
c'est ces français qui disent qu'on en
fait trop sur l'ukraine il ya beaucoup
de français mais on est présent aussi on
fait une partie des français qui dit
voilà nous avons là on a peur qui est
trop de sanctions et que en france ça
nous impacte comme il a dit sur les
revenants sur la loi 101 sur l'essence
sur tout ça clément guérin peut-être le
plus jeune de l'équipe vous comment où
et surtout aussi et les jeunes aussi
sont voilà vous vous dites quoi vous moi
je dis à haut niveau livre que ça fait
deux ans qu'il qui se présente comme le
fpi deux épidémiologistes virologues par
rapport aux copines maintenant ils et
géopolitologue visiblement et donc
justement je parlais joe cole
géopolitologue et je lui demande
concrètement qu'est ce qui fait à la
place d'emmanuel mac rhône qui est
président de l'europe y fait rien si en
fait tu vas chercher la désescalade
parce qu'on va continuer d elecam et
puis
c'est le parrainer un million de
demander une table ronde avec tous les
acteurs en fait qui ont fait monter
cette pression on se rappelle quand même
des états unis qu'on entend plus bas il
donne qui est planqué chez lui il est en
week-end la semaine dernière pendant que
les ukrainiens pour na des bombes sur là
je suis d'accord quand même la vérité
complet juste manqué lui je suis
évidemment parce qu'on va proposer une
vraie table ronde et oui je suis désolé
de le dire il va falloir que chacun y
mette du sien des deux côtés si on veut
dire
quelle direction les bons pour aller
prendre nous-mêmes après sur la gueule à
temps que ça s'arrête sergei et et tu
vas olive je suis d'accord que vaille de
tripoli ce fort niveau car il
donc ein hod et ses planques et tout le
monde le sait on peut pas le nier donc
ça c'est vrai que l'europe était plus
active que les etats-unis et peut-être
c'est l'europe ne dénonce pas au mieux
c'est peut-être tant mieux de chance oui
parce que à la limite on lui reproche
d'être partout
il donne aux états unis et quand
inferior on lui propose de ne rien faire
pression et une fois qu'il a fait monter
la pression l'entend plus c'est pas
normal jean c'est vous dire une fierté
mantel après d'accord avec ce que dit
aussi poutine quand on a quand même
manqué mon fils radim vous êtes d'un
mépris envers au libouli parce que c'est
un citoyen engagé et qu'il est
journaliste
on n'a pas de
lui en tout cas je suis aux citoyens aux
poses des questions d'asile devraient se
poser il se mange des questions de plein
de français que se pose absolument qui
vous cloue le bec ce soir parce que vous
attendiez vous dis ça parce que je
défends la russie et à l'ukraine
pourrait dans la provoc or il a des
propos mesurés il se pose des questions
que les tous les gens c est attristé
d'accord elle que vous êtes
condescendant avec la crise ochoa ouais
parce que vous lui et vous l'attaquez
lui au lieu de répondre à ce qui dit
il dit pas que la guerre c'est mal ils
s'inquiètent du niveau de sanction et de
niveau d'implication dans un conflit qui
à la base ne nous regarde pas jusqu'à
dire que ministre le ministre le porte
parole du ministère des armées hier a
dit la france n'est pas en guerre contre
la russie il a dit et maquereau
et moi aussi macron n'est pas n'est pas
aussi en garde l'allemagne en battant la
dioxine et à la france voilà non mais
oui mais il ya énormément de fonction
donc ils s'inquiètent aussi pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français
à quoi bon tu en fais rien et donne ses
collègues ont laissé l'ukraine et la
russie se taper dessus
j'avais entendu derrière c'est à 10
heures par an leur qualité l'armée il a
dit qu'on fait en fait je vous dis donc
on va pas se mentir les sanctions pour
contre la russie est-ce alors en touche
une sans faire bouger met donc en fait
il son vertige totalement dont 4,6 où il
ya une intervention militaire
cécile arrêter ben voyons vous avez vu
vous avez
un changement vous versez parisien et
il a bien dit hier le portant les
ministères dernier on la france
n'interviendra pas militairement en
ukraine puisque l'ukraine ne fait pas
partie de l'otan c'est tout et si un
autre pays est touché comme la pologne
la roumanie et toucher oui là on
interviendra au chaud donc alors c'est
vrai que les sanctions pour l'instant on
peut pas dire parce que tout le monde
dit oui les sanctions en fonction je
voulais dire vous êtes toujours à dire
ça les sanctions des sanctions
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui ça qu'est ce
qui a changé voilà l'europe n'a shooté
quoi les honneurs au delà chuté mais les
russes ont ri de la monnaie
mais poutine et la recul et non ce
qu'ils ont innocence non mais c'est vrai
c'est ma question à lui d'ailleurs trop
tôt c'est raide mais c'est au niveau 5
les yeux noirs alors je mène mais c'est
trop tôt et s'est aussi trop tard c'est
trop tôt que c'est trop tard mais
heureusement et on leur dit c'est vrai
que le président l'a pratiquement tous
les jours au téléphone justement pour
l'avoir encore voilà avoir un contact
explique céline expansé pas un os non on
sait pas jusqu'où il va aller leur télé
que ça je vais vous dire il faut
toujours il faut toujours tant qu on a
vu alors qu'il a eue loppsi savoir qu'on
a me contacter si ratio ridicule dit ah
non ça c'est moi je suis pas d'accord je
vous dis pas que ça sert à rien je dis
qu'en fait les en fait les discussions
faudra qu'il soit plus ouverte et que
les siciliens ont fait des concessions
mais non mais en étant honnête soyons
honnête j'étais sûr si je rentre ne fait
pas de concessions et que poutine ne
fait pas de conception afin que chacun y
mette du sien sinon on aura une escalade
et là ça risque de devenir de kiel et là
par exemple je suis d'accord énorme mais
comment tu fais tu tu imposes à poutine
comment tu demandes à poutine de faire
les conceptions qu'est ce qui ne va pas
je pensais que tu veux je suis confronté
valverde a
discuté aux pressions de discuter l'on
voit ici là où je vous rejoins c'est que
on pourrait même dire que sur le plan
militaire il ya une forme d'hypocrisie
et là tu rejoins dont ils volaient est à
dire qu on s'arrête à la frontière on
ferme les yeux en disant tant que ça va
pas chez nous l'otan on n'y touche pas
et on sait ferme les yeux c'est la règle
mais c'est une forme d'hypocrisie
quelques
ça veut dire que les sanctions c'est
vrai que les sanctions domaine inconnu
qu crise' aussi ça aurait été de ne rien
faire et c'est vrai que la france et le
le président on verra ce qu'on voudra a
prédit il est quand même et oui quand
même il est quand même très présents sur
ce dossier en mai milliards non ça
n'avance pas oui non mais militairement
c'est normal
mais plus largement c'est une question
au niveau livre parce que vous arrêtez
pas d'ironie vos livres oui mais il faut
faire une table de pourparlers trouver
une solution le plus vite possible le
plus rapidement possible avec le temps
avec les états unis mais en fait tu ne
veux pas l'otan puisque justement il
exècre que les cra n va éventuellement
rentrée 2010 il voulait que l'ukraine
dans l'otan jeudi qu'il faut qu'ils
discutent ensemble pour essayer de
trouver des diacres pas il écoute il ne
veut pas que l'ukraine dont il est le
fait que l'ukraine à l'otan parce qu'il
va voir l'ukraine sous tutelle et comme
chez nous il sait très bien que ça va
passer sous la tutelle des états unis
l'europe encore là c'est sur
l'histoire de l'ukraine a laissé une
influence ou et américaines en russe et
vladimir poutine veut pas perdre son
influence sur l'ukraine et c'est pour ça
qu'il veut pas qu'ils rejoignent le
temps et les états unis avaient promis à
vladimir poutine
toujours promis que l'ukraine ne
rejoindrait jamais l'otan s'est changé
l'histoire des histoires elle est là en
vérité
destin oui oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aux livres 6 là par
exemple poutine a dit oui au niveau
livre il ya une heure ou deux poutine a
dit moi je veux bien revenir aux fins de
négocier mais je négocie si on accepte
toutes mes conditions donc ce n'est pas
une négociation il faut espérer il faut
espérer que chacun y mette du sien je
suis entièrement d'accord
mais il faut déjà au moins se mettre à
la table déjà faut se mettre à la
corbeille aller si on n'accepte pas ces
conditions non mais quoi tu vas faire
une discussion tu peux pas dire on va
venir être façon nous accepter il faut
quand même accepté de devenir disputé à
la va essayer d'apaiser les choses